where's the ring this is probably one of
the worst things i've ever done in my
whole life your engagement ring
hysterically crying in my closet or like
no hours
kourtney kardashian reveals she broke
her engagement ring from travis barker
oh
let's rewind the 46 year old blink 182
drummer popped the question on the beach
in montecito california back in october
with a jaw-dropping lorraine schwartz
sparkler and during the latest episode
of the famous family's new hulu series
the 43 year old push founder admits she
accidentally crushed it this is probably
one of the worst things i've ever done
in my whole life by the way
i was sitting on my floor folding
sweatshirts yeah and i took the ring off
and i put it next to me on the floor
like thinking it would be safe right
next to me and get to the punch line so
then i had to get something up above in
my closet and when i stepped down i
stepped on the ring
you broke
your engagement ring hysterically crying
in my closet or like no hours
and court she says she called trav in
tears to break the bad news
i was like i did something really really
bad
and he handled it the best but it was
really
like a nervous breakdown gonna give me a
nervous break and i was just like this
is the most beautiful thing that i've
ever had in my life and how so did i
done that travis picked it out he
designed it he looked at so many stones
and that this was like me in a stone and
so i thought that that was really
special ring drama aside kravis is set
to tie the knot but for now the love
birds are staying tight-lipped about
their wedding plans
when is the wedding and what will that
look like because we're really seeing
your love story with your soul mate on
the new show we don't know yet we're
just you know living our best lives
but they did say i do in an unofficial
las vegas wedding back in april and
cameras have been documenting their
journey to have a child together
we want it so badly because we want to
make something together what has it been
like to be on the path to baby with
travis i mean it's a beautiful thing
that we'd love to have happen
but
you know the journey is a bit hard for
any women who have been on it and
emotional
of course courtney shears three kids
with her ex scott disick twelve-year-old
mason nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign while travis has
two kids of his own with his ex shayna
mookler 18 year old landon and 16 year
old alabama our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
the kardashians are good to my kids you
know that's all that matters to me as a
mom and while fans continue to root for
court and travis to have a little baby
barker we'll just send you off with all
the feels just check out what the
musician told kris jenner about why he
really moved to court's neighborhood
he said because i knew she lived in
calabasas and i knew she was the love of
my life and i didn't even know her like
that but i just knew
if i couldn't date her be with her
because she was with someone else
that at least i could live by her
i've never met
a better human in my life
[Music]
you